l'invité politique de la matinale on va
également aborder la situation sanitaire
du pays on retrouve tout de suite
benjamin lucas porte parole de
générations
[Musique]
benjamin lucas bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation d'un matinale de
rtl france alors vous êtes coordinateur
national porte parole de générations
alors avant de revenir sur la situation
sanitaire le week-end a été marqué on
vient de le voir par des propos
antisémites tenus sur les réseaux
sociaux à l'encontre de appris le bénin
yum
c'est la première dauphine de miss
france 2000 21 de nombreuses
personnalités politiques ou des
associations se sont indignées
on regarde quelques réactions et puis on
en parle après l'anonymat sert de
paravent à la haine nous demandons à
twitter de tout mettre en oeuvre pour
permettre à la justice d'identifier sept
nostalgiques de la shoah
nous devons pouvoir lui dire dans les
yeux à la barre du tribunal ce que
signifie sa haine des juifs
suite aux attaques et menaces
antisémites contre april benayoun miss
provence et candidates miss france
j'appelle à l'ouverture d'une enquête
contre ses agresseurs
ils doivent être condamnés lourdement
est bannie des réseaux sociaux la haine
antisémite qui s'est exercée notamment
sur twitter contre april benayoun est
épouvantable dans cette matrice de
violence le peuple juif est haï pour la
seule raison qu'il est juif
mon soutien total à april et à toutes
les victimes de l'antisémitisme alors
jamais le cas quels mots m à 8x les ses
réactions a durant l'élection de miss
france qui est pourtant un
divertissement à la base révèle-t-il de
notre société que la bête immonde de
l'antisémitisme n'a pas encore été
vaincue et nous le savions et quand on
voit le déferlement abominable
abominable d'antisémitisme ou de racisme
qui peut se déverser quotidiennement sur
les réseaux sociaux et qui a explosé ce
week end
on voit là qu'il faut une réponse
judiciaire pénal à la hauteur de ce que
cela dit de péril pour notre démocratie
donc là je crois qu'il faut la plus
grande fermeté vous avez cité les
acteurs politiques condamnent ses propos
je m'y associe bien évidemment
je crois que là il est temps que la plus
grande sévérité à l'égard de ces
comportements sur les réseaux sociaux et
que effectivement soit soient traqués et
condamné celles et ceux qui commettent
ce genre de délit alors l'actualité
c'est aussi bien sur la situation
sanitaire l'exécutif
on en parlait au début de cette édition
a interdit les liaisons avec la
grande-bretagne depuis minuit en raison
de la nouvelle souche est ce que vous
vous saluer cette décision rapide du
gouvernement
on se souvient que la question de la
fermeture des frontières avaient posé
question lors de la première vague
oui moi je pense que le gouvernement à
faire face à des missions compliquées je
crois que cette décision va dans le bon
sens ce n'est pas la quantité
d'informations dont dispose le
gouvernement donc là aussi je fais
confiance aux autorités
et je crois que globalement en revanche
c'est cette crise il est important qu'on
ait un débat démocratique de saint
seurin on y reviendra sans doute à
travers la culture mais que toutes les
décisions doivent être mieux expliquer
sans doute et mieux débattue par les
représentants démocratiques de nos
concitoyens alors justement la culture
le conseil d'état va examiner
aujourd'hui harcourt qu'est ce que vous
attendez de cette décision de la plus
haute juridiction administrative qu'on
revienne à une situation pas dans une
situation normale puisque on est dans
une crise sanitaire mais priver notre
pays culture je crois que c'est très
grave c'est on sortira pas de cette
crise s'est tenue dans votre reportage
par une dame on a besoin de la culture y
compris pour sortir de cette crise c'est
pas la culture qui va nous vacciner ce
n'est pas la culture qui va faire
s'effondrer l'épidémie mais on a besoin
de vivre et la culture fait partie de
ces parties de la vie et nos concitoyens
ne comprennent pas personne ne peut
comprendre qu'on laisse ouvert des
grandes surfaces commerciales personne
ne peut comprendre qu'on puisse
s'agglutiner dans les transports en
commun et que là où le monde de la
culture en plus ça fait preuve de
beaucoup d'inventivité pour mettre en
oeuvre les protocoles sanitaires
permettre une circulation et ses bas
qu'il reste qu'il reste fermé je crois
que c'est un très mauvais signal aussi
que nous adressons à ce secteur qui la
danse que j'entends
ne demande pas l'aumône demandent à
pouvoir faire ce que sont tous ces
métiers de la culture normalement elle
nous offrira nous un peu de bonheur un
peu d'espoir un peu d'intelligence dans
ce moment particulièrement dramatique
pour notre pays et pour le monde
alors beaucoup d'incompréhension
provoqué par les mesures restrictives un
liées à la crise sanitaire alors que le
chef de l'état lui-même été contaminées
il participait c'était mercredi dernier
à ce fameux dîner à l'elysée une
polémique s'en est suivie la députée
marie-christine verdier joucla est venu
au secours du chef de l'état voyez ce
qu'elle a dit chez nos confrères de lcp
je ne comprends pas qu'on puisse faire
une polémique autour de ça on parle de
qui on parle du président de la
république on parle du chef de l'état on
parle de celui qui a la responsabilité
aujourd'hui que toutes les françaises et
les français soient protégés qu'ils
bossent 24 heures sur 24 pour nous
sortir de cette situation et où est ce
que vous comprenez finalement que le
chef de l'état il en a besoin de ces
réunions de travail il est président il
doit il doit avancer et donc c'est
normal finalement que ce dîner et puisse
tenir qu'est ce que vous en pensez
deux choses d'abord j'ai bien ce député
que remettra en cause les actes et les
propos du chef de l'état ça s'appelle la
démocratie
et moi je suis heureux que nous soyons
dans une démocratie ce n'est pas le cas
partout dans le monde
donc oui en france on peut commenter
critiquer mettre en cause les décisions
et les actes du chef de l'état que
soient fondées ou infondées ça s'appelle
la démocratie tant qu on le fait dans le
respect de la loi et dans le respect de
sa personne
ensuite sur le comportement du président
de la république lui-même moi je ne suis
pas pour dire que le présente je pense
le président a accueilli est un homme
comme les autres qui est soumis aux
mêmes lois que les autres il a une
fonction qui par sa nature est
évidemment une fonction qui n'est pas
n'importe laquelle dans la république
qu'est la fonction principale de notre
république donc de ce point de vue là
moi je crois que c'est normal qu'il
puisse déroger à certaines règles pour
l'exercice de sa fonction
la question est est ce que ce dîner
était nécessaire à l'exercice de sa
fonction de président de la république
la réponse qu'on à travers la presse et
que non puisque c'était un dîner de la
majorité pour cent mille parler la
proportionnelle aux élections
législatives sans doute parler des
élections régionales par les impôts de
tambouille électorale je vois pas en
quoi la présence de monsieur castaner
président de groupe majoritaire la
présence de monsieur bayrou chef de
partie les autres chefs de parti était
indispensable et donc de ce point de vue
là
le présent la république aurait pu
aurait dû respecter le couvre feu
respecté la consigne de la limitation de
6 ha tamm plutôt que de donner ce
mauvais exemple donc pour moi qu'il y
dérogent pour des réunions d'intérêt
national en revanche là je pense que sur
skype zoom ou en tout cas sur les via le
numérique vous pouvez très bien parler à
monsieur castaner monsieur bayrou alors
le week end a par ailleurs été marquée
par de nouvelles manifestations contre
la loi sécurité globale global avec une
mobilisation certes moins importante
qu'auparavant
toujours au coeur de débats ce fameux
article 24 on en a beaucoup parlé
l'exécutif a assuré sa réécriture pour
vous est ce que c'est une bonne loi
notamment pour la protection des
policiers non c'est une loi liberticide
qui a été dicté au ministre de
l'intérieur par un syndicat policier
d'extrême droite et le syndicat alliance
et avec la faiblesse et la complicité du
présent la république et du premier
ministre je crois que c'est une mauvaise
loi qu'elle remet en cause des principes
essentiels de nos libertés qu'elle est
contestée par pas seulement par les
manifestants dont je suis elle est
contestée par un certain nombre
d'acteurs des libertés d'avocats de
magistrats d'organisations
internationales
encore une fois la france donne d'elle
une image terrible à travers le monde
puisque nous sommes le pays de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen nous sommes dans notre
constitution
des défenseurs des libertés que là nous
avons un gouvernement qui est finalement
mène une politique pour laquelle il n'a
pas été élu parce que je rappelle qu
emmanuel macron a été élu pour faire
barrage à l'extrême droite de marine le
pen et à cette tentation autoritaire
merci beaucoup benjamin lucas d'avoir
accepté ce matin notre invitation je le
rappelle vous êtes coordinateur national
et porte parole de générations